Hello, and hello!
Welcome to the 68th Annual Golden Globe Awards live in the Beverly Hilton Hotel in Los Angeles.
It's gonna be a night of partying and heavy drinking...
...or as Charlie Sheen calls it, "breakfast".
What did he do on New Year's Eve?
Anyway, welcome!
The Golden Globes is a celebration of the best in TV and movies over the last year...
...voted for by the Hollywood Foreign Press Association.
It was a big year for 3D movies:...
...Toy Story, Despicable Me, Tron.
It seems like everything this year was three-dimensional...
...except the characters in The Tourist.
It must be good 'cause it's nominated.
So, shut up, okay?
And I'd like to quash this ridiculous rumor going around...
...that the only reason The Tourist was nominated...
...was so the Hollywood Foreign Press could hang out with Johnny Depp and Angelina Jolie.
That is rubbish.
That is not the only reason.
They also accepted bribes.
No, all that happened was some of them were taken to see Cher in concert.
How the hell is that a bribe?
Really? Do you wanna go see Cher?
No!
Why not?
'Cause it's not 1975.
There's been some great new TV drama this year...
...like Boardwalk Empire and The Walking Dead. So, yeah!
Talking of The Walking Dead,...
...congratulations to Hugh Hefner who's getting married, at the age of 84,...
...to 24-year-old beauty Crystal Harris.
When she was asked why she was marrying him,...
...she said, "'Cause he lied about his age,"...
..."he told me he was 94."
Oh, come on!